that you would think she would
be considering all of the time
she has spent planning this.
>> Something I have to ask you,
because you worked in the trump
white house.
There is this dominion lawsuit
against fox that has been in
the news.
In recent days, what has really
indicated is how the fox hosts
would go out there and say one
thing on TV but then say
something completely different
to themselves about the former
president for example.
And his election lies and so on
about the 2020 election.
But one of the other things I
remember covering in the white
house is how, I mean, there is
almost a hand and glove, you
know, sometimes fox and the
white house were on the same
page with the same talking
points that it almost seemed
like he would see hosts like
Laura Ingraham visiting the
white house.
It almost seemed as though
there was a pretty cozy
relationship between the white
house and fox.
Is that how you remember it?
What do you recall from that
experience?
PTSD, right now.
But yes, very cozy
relationship.
You know, I would have judge
Jeanine or Sean or tucker
calling me, and if I didn't get
back to them right away they
would then call the president.
And then I would get a talking
to for not speaking with them.
I remember specifically working
on a town hall that the
president, the former president
did with fox.
And me having to talk directly
to Suzanne Scott about making
sure that she was full in
their.
We did work hand in hand with
them.
That came out the president's
direction.
If he didn't like something, we
would immediately call fox and
have them fix it or try to make
a new story out of, it et
cetera.
>> Incredible, I mean, that is
a lot of what we observed on
the outside in the press.
You know, you would see hannity
at a trump rally and that kind
of thing.
But just what you are seeing
right now, Stephanie, I think
is some insights that we
haven't really heard before
about this cozy relationship
that it was going on between
fox and the trump white house.
Molly.
>> Obviously, 2020 is always,
hindsight is always 2020,
looking back that was
completely unethical, frankly,
as a comms person.
So I do apologize for that.
But that is how it worked.